It's peak pollination season and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore GoogleFi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢再喧闹，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为每月 35 美元。这可真是一个不会长久的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需税费和政府规费。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Speaking of psychology is taking a summer break, so we're rerunning some of our favorite episodes from the past. In 2022, I talked to psychologist and friendship expert Marissa Franco about how to make new friends as an adult and how to strengthen or rekindle old friendship ties. I hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. We'll be back with new episodes in a few weeks. When you were a kid, making friends might have seemed easy and natural. You were surrounded by potential playmates at school and on the playground, and friendships just seem to happen. And college may have been another situation where friendships easily blossomed. But for many adults,
在网络使用高峰期，Google Fi Wireless 不会遭遇数据流量优先级降低的情况。说到“心理学之声”正在进行暑期休假，因此我们将重播过去的一些最爱单集。2022 年，我与心理学家兼友谊专家玛丽莎·弗兰科（Marissa Franco）探讨了成年后如何结交新朋友，以及如何加深或重燃过去的友谊纽带。希望您喜欢这期来自档案库的节目。几周后我们将携新节目回归。当您还是个孩子的时候，交朋友似乎既轻松又自然。你的周围到处都是学校和操场上的潜在玩伴，友谊似乎就这样自然而然地发生了。大学可能是另一个友谊轻易绽放的环境。但对许多成年人来说，
making new friends and maintaining old friendships is more difficult. We're all busy with work, our partners, child care, and other grown-up responsibilities, and friendships often end up taking a backseat to the other priorities in our lives. Why is that? Why is it so hard to make friends as an adult, and why don't we prioritize friendship more? If you want to make new friends, what's the best way to do it? What about strengthening and rekindling old friendship ties? What are the essential ingredients of being a good friend, and how do you know which friendships are worth the effort to maintain? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
结交新朋友和维持老朋友变得更加困难。我们都忙于工作、伴侣、育儿和其他成年人的责任，友谊往往退居生活中的其他优先级之后。这是为什么呢？为什么成年后交朋友这么难，为什么我们没有把友谊放在更重要的位置？如果你想结交新朋友，最好的方法是什么？如何加强和重燃旧友谊？成为一个好朋友的基本要素是什么，你怎么知道哪些友谊值得付出努力去维护？欢迎收看《心理学之声》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Marissa Franco, a psychologist and friendship expert who is working on a book about friendship called Plotonic, due out later this year. Dr. Franco is a counseling psychologist and an assistant clinical professor at the University of Maryland. She was previously an assistant professor of psychology at Georgia State University. She writes a blog on friendship for psychology today and has also written for or given interviews about friendship to many news outlets, including
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是玛丽莎·弗兰科博士，她是一位心理学家和友谊专家，正在撰写一本名为《柏拉图式》（Platonic）的关于友谊的书，该书将于今年晚些时候出版。弗兰科博士是一位咨询心理学家，也是马里兰大学的临床助理教授。她曾任佐治亚州立大学心理学助理教授。她为《今日心理学》（Psychology Today）撰写关于友谊的博客，并曾为许多新闻媒体撰写文章或接受采访，其中包括
scientific American and the New York Times to name just a couple. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Franco. Happy to be here. Thank you so much for having me. Let's start with a question I posed in the introduction. Why does it seem like it's so much harder to make friends as we get older? Is it that we're busy with adult responsibilities or is there more to it? I think that it's the context that we're in. So sociologists have argued that there's a few ingredients that need to be at play for friendship
《科学美国人》和《纽约时报》等。非常感谢您今天加入我们，弗兰科博士。很高兴来到这里。非常感谢邀请我。让我们从我在引言中提出的问题开始。为什么随着年龄的增长，交朋友似乎变得越来越难？是因为我们忙于成年人的责任，还是有更深层的原因？我认为这是我们所处的环境决定的。因此，社会学家认为，要让友谊
to happen organically. And that's continuous unplanned interaction and shared vulnerability. And we have that when we're younger. You know, like at school, we're on the playground. We have recess. We have all these clubs. But as we move on into adulthood, we're not in a lot of environments that allow for continuous unplanned interaction and shared vulnerability. I mean, like work gives us continuous unplanned interaction, but often there's professionalism norms where people aren't actually sharing a lot about themselves, and so that really impedes connection. And so I think it's just that we no longer find ourselves in the environments that have the right conditions for friendship unless we intentionally seek them out as adults. Is there an age when this becomes particularly apparent or some stage
有机地发生，需要具备几个要素。这就是持续的、无计划的互动和共同的脆弱性。当我们年轻的时候，我们具备这些。你知道，就像在学校里，我们在操场上。我们有课间休息。我们有各种各样的俱乐部。但随着我们进入成年期，我们所处的环境并不多，无法进行持续的、无计划的互动以及展现共同的脆弱性。我的意思是，比如工作为我们提供了持续的、无计划的互动，但通常存在职业规范，人们实际上并不分享太多关于自己的事情，这确实阻碍了连接。所以我认为，这只是因为我们不再处于具备交友正确条件的环境中，除非我们在成年后刻意去寻找它们。有没有哪个年龄段，这种情况变得尤为明显，或者在人生的某个阶段
of life when people realize that it's gotten harder to make friends? Yeah, I mean, I would argue that it tends to start after college where you no longer have that environment. But what we see in the research is that people actually have the most friends in their young to mid-20s, and then it tends to taper out over time. Some of this is actually arguably good. There's a theory called the socio-emotional selectivity hypothesis, which basically argues and finds that as we get older, we focus more on quality rather than quantity because we're thinking, you know, I have X amount of time left and when I spend it with people that really matter. Whereas when we're younger, we're focused on expanding our sense of identity.
人们意识到交朋友变得更难了？是的，我的意思是，我认为它往往始于大学之后，那时你不再拥有那样的环境。但我们在研究中看到的是，人们实际上在 20 岁出头到 25 岁左右拥有的朋友最多，然后随着时间的推移，朋友数量往往会逐渐减少。其中一些实际上可以说是件好事。有一个名为“社会情感选择性假设”的理论，该理论基本上认为并发现，随着年龄的增长，我们更多地关注质量而不是数量，因为我们在想，你知道的，我的时间是有限的，我要把它花在真正重要的人身上。而当我们年轻时，我们专注于拓展我们的身份认同感。
So we're just like, I'm going to be open, all different types of people who are going to show me new and different things. So just what tends to happen is that we shrink our circles over time, but I'm not exactly sure if that's because it's getting harder or because we're also doing so intentionally. So in a recent article, you referenced a study that found that people on average have fewer friends than they used to. Friendship networks seem to have shrunk over the past several decades. why do you think that's happening and is that a problem? Absolutely. I mean, the recent research has found, and this was conducted in the pandemic. So that's a caveat that compared to like decades ago, people are four to five times more
所以我们只是觉得：我要保持开放的心态，结识所有不同类型的人，他们会向我展示新的和不同的事物。所以往往发生的情况是，随着时间的推移，我们的社交圈缩小了，但我并不完全确定这是因为交友变得越来越难，还是因为我们也在刻意这样做。因此，在最近的一篇文章中，您引用了一项研究，该研究发现人们平均拥有的朋友比过去少了。在过去几十年里，友谊网络似乎缩小了。您认为为什么会这样？这是否是一个问题？绝对是的。我的意思是，最近的研究发现——这是在疫情期间进行的。所以这是一个需要注意的前提——与几十年前相比，人们交不到朋友的可能性
likely to have no friends. And it's worse among men compared to, I think it was like a few decades ago, like early 90s. The amount of men that have no friends has has risen fivefold and fourfold for women. And so other meta-analys and meta-analys just combined research amongst a bunch of different studies have been finding that our friendship networks have been decreasing over time. And I think that this is a crisis. It's a public health crisis because, you know, loneliness is as toxic for our bodies as smoking 15 cigarettes a day, the science finds. For our longevity, actually, our social connection matters more than even our diet and our exercise, according to various meta-analyses. And so having friends, having connection for us as social creatures, it's just central to our health
高出四到五倍。而且男性的情况比……我想大概是几十年前，比如 90 年代初更糟糕。没有朋友的男性数量增加了五倍，女性则增加了四倍。因此，其他元分析——元分析只是结合了多项不同研究的研究成果——一直发现我们的友谊网络随着时间的推移一直在减少。我认为这是一场危机。这是一场公共卫生危机，因为正如科学发现的那样，孤独对我们身体的毒害就像一天抽 15 根烟一样。根据各种元分析，实际上为了我们的长寿，我们的社交连接甚至比我们的饮食和锻炼更重要。因此，对于作为社会生物的我们来说，拥有朋友、拥有连接对我们的健康至关重要，
and also just central to our sense of identity for us to feel like ourselves, for us to be able to explore who we are. Often we find pieces of ourselves and other people and we begin to incorporate that and that's how we feel enriched and that's how we feel full. And so I think as our friendship start to decline, we're going to see more health issues alongside feelings of just like social on ease or sort of like identity issues. So in your writing, you offer advice for people about how to make new friends and how to maintain friendship. So let's start with the first. What do you advise people who really want to make new friends, say someone who's just moved to a new city and is feeling lonely, doesn't know anybody. Yeah. So for people to make new friends, I recommend initiating. Right.
对我们的身份认同感也至关重要，这能让我们感觉自己就是自己，让我们能够探索自己是谁。通常我们在别人身上找到自己的部分并开始将其实际融合，这就是我们感到丰富的方式，这就是我们感到充实的方式。因此，我认为随着我们的友谊开始减少，除了感到社交不安或某种身份认同问题之外，我们还会看到更多的健康问题。所以在你的著作中，你为人们提供了关于如何结交新朋友以及如何维护友谊的建议。让我们从第一点开始。你对那些非常想结交新朋友的人有什么建议，比如说刚搬到一个新城市、感到孤独、谁都不认识的人。好的。对于想要结交新朋友的人，我建议主动出击。对吧？
We tend to rely on this myth that friendship happens organically so we don't put ourselves out there. But actually, the science finds that people that see friendship as something that doesn't take effort are more lonely over time, whereas those that see friendship as taking effort are less lonely. And that's because they make the effort. I think the biggest problem is that we tend to be so self-defeating. We tend to fear rejection. We tend to think that, you know, if I reach out, they won't want to talk to me. But in fact, that's a bias that we all have.
我们往往依赖于一种神话，即友谊是自然发生的，所以我们不会主动表现自己。但事实上，科学发现，那些认为友谊不需要付出努力的人随着时间推移会更加孤独，而那些认为友谊需要付出努力的人则不那么孤独。这是因为他们付出了努力。我认为最大的问题是，我们往往自我挫败感太强。我们倾向于害怕被拒绝。我们往往会想，你知道的，如果我主动联系，他们可能不会想跟我说话。但事实上，这是我们所有人都有的一种偏见，
necessarily true according to the research. There's a study on a phenomenon called the liking gap wherein the researchers had people interact. And afterwards, each person was asked, hey, how much do you like the person that you interacted with? And the study actually found that people underestimated how like they were by the other person. And the more self-critical people were, the more pronounced this bias was to underestimate how much people like them. And so my advice to people who are thinking about initiating a little bit more is to get into the right mindset, which was going to require you to begin to assume that people like you. And then going out there and initiating with new people is going to look a lot easier. And just to make this super practical,
根据研究，这并不一定符合事实。有一项关于“喜爱差距”（liking gap）现象的研究，研究人员让人们进行互动。事后，每个人都被问到：嘿，你有多喜欢跟你互动的那个人？研究实际发现，人们低估了自己被对方喜欢的程度。人们越是自我批判，这种低估别人有多喜欢自己的偏见就越明显。因此，我对那些考虑再多主动一点的人的建议是，要进入正确的心态，这就需要你开始假设别人是喜欢你的。然后，走出去与新人主动互动就会显得容易得多。为了让这一点变得超级切实可行，
what does this look like? Simply saying a line like, hey, I really enjoyed talking to you. I'd love to stay connected, exchanging contact information, following up from there. So we just have to put ourselves out there, really take the risk and reap the benefits. Yeah, take the risk, reap the benefits, and believe that there will be benefits. Maintain your optimism, because if you're self-defeated, it's going to become a self-fulfilling prophecy. So what about someone whose concern is more about maintaining and deepening friendships rather than making new ones? Maybe we're talking about a new parent who's working full time and finding that old friendships are falling by the wayside. What are some tips for them?
这具体是什么样子的？很简单地说一句：“嘿，我真的很喜欢和你聊天。我很想保持联系”，交换联系信息，然后进行后续跟进。所以我们只需要展现自己，真正承担风险并收获成果。是的，承担风险，收获成果，并相信会有成果。保持乐观，因为如果你自我击败，它就会变成一个自我实现的预言。那么，对于那些更关心维持和加深友谊而不是结交新朋友的人呢？也许我们谈论的是一位全职工作的新父母，发现老朋友正在逐渐疏远。对他们有什么建议吗？
Yeah, so you want to create your own continuous unplanned interaction. So I would say, schedule a monthly meeting on your calendar for you and your friend to catch up and put it there so that it's there and you don't have to figure out when can we find the time. It's there automatically so that you can find that time to connect. Other things that I would suggest is taking that assuming people like you and applying it to old friendships you want to rekindle too, right? Because often we don't reach out to these old friends because we're sort of like, oh, maybe they're not interested. They've moved on. They're have all these other things going on in their life, they're too busy. But instead, hey, they're probably wanting to hear from me and they're probably wondering about me too. And that being the mindset that can allow you to actually reach out to some people that you want to connect to. The other thing that I would say is as we become more busy, one way to keep friends is to incorporate friends in a goal that you would like to set for yourself. So maybe that's like, I want to walk more and finding time to go on walk with friends or I want
是的，所以你要创造你自己的持续、无计划的互动。所以我会说：在你的日历上为自己和你的朋友安排一次每月的会面，把它放进去，这样它就在那里了，你就不必去想我们什么时候能抽出时间。它会自动出现在那里，这样你就可以找到那个时间去连接。我建议的另一件事是，采取“假设别人喜欢你”的心态，并把它应用到你也想重燃的旧友谊中，对吧？因为通常我们不联系这些老朋友，是因为我们在想：“噢，也许他们不感兴趣。他们已经继续前进了。他们的生活中有那么多其他事情，他们太忙了。”但相反，嘿，他们可能很想听到我的消息，他们可能也在想我。这种心态可以让你真正向一些你想联系的人伸出援手。我要说的另一件事是，随着我们变得越来越忙，维系朋友的一个方法是将朋友纳入你为自己设定的目标中。所以也许就像：我想多走路，并找时间跟朋友一起去散步；或者我想吃得健康，并找时间跟朋友一起做饭，因为这为你提供了一个维系友谊的锚点。这给了你一个借口。这赋予了互动规律性。这对维持连接非常重要。所以顺着这一点往下问，你怎么知道一段友谊是否值得投入这种努力？我的意思是，这真的是那个价值 6.4 万美元的问题。什么才算是一段好的友谊？是的。我的意思是，互惠的早期迹象是非常有希望的。比如你主动联系他们，他们也在主动联系你。对朋友来说非常重要的一点是，那些为你成功而欢呼的人。当你分享好消息时，他们为你感到高兴吗？
to eat healthy and finding time to cook with friends because that gives you something to anchor your friendship around. That gives you the excuse. That gives you the regularity of the interaction. That's really important for maintaining the connection. So to follow up on that, how do you know that a friendship is worth investing that kind of effort in? I mean, this is really the $64,000 question. What makes for a good friendship? Yeah. I mean, early signs of reciprocity are very promising. like you reach out and they're also reaching out to you. What's really important for friends is people that are rooting for your success. When you share good news, are they happy for you?
他们为你感到兴奋吗？研究实际上发现，这一点可以预测我们在关系中的满意程度，甚至比某人在我们难过时是否陪伴在我们身边更能说明问题。所以这真的很重要。我们需要一个关心我们、为我们着想的人。另一件事是，我真的很喜欢这个概念。它被称为“身份确认”。这意味着我们寻找那些支持我们成为我们想成为的人的朋友，
Are they excited for you? Research studies actually find that this predicts how satisfied we are in the relationship, even more so than whether someone shows up for us when we're sad. So that's really important. We want someone who is looking out for us, what's the best for us? The other thing is, I really love this concept. It's called identity affirmation. and that means we look for friends who support us in becoming the person that we want to be
而不是把他们认为我们应该成为什么样的人强加给我们，对吧？所以，如果一个身份确认度很高的人，如果我告诉他们：“哦，我想辞职，去墨西哥参加一个密集的西班牙语班”，对吧？他们可能会想：“哦，天哪，我绝对不会做那种事。太冒险了。”但他们会理解这是我的价值观，对吧？理解这是我喜欢的东西——冒险。因此，他们能够说：“我真为你感到高兴。
rather than imposing who they think we should be on us, right? So someone who's high in identity affirmation, if I tell them, oh, I want to quit my job and take an intensive Spanish class in Mexico, right? They might think, oh my gosh, I would never do something like that. That's so risky. But they would understand that these are my values, right? That this is what I enjoy, adventure. And so they would be able to say, I'm so happy for you.
我想支持你，因为我理解这与你的目标相符。”事实上，研究发现这可以预测最好的友谊是否能随着时间的推移而维持。我们是否提供了那种身份确认？另一件非常重要的事情是换位思考。不健康的关系，有毒的关系。通常在换位思考上会出现断层。我只想着我的需求。我没有考虑你的需求。
I want to support you because I understand that that aligns with your goals. And that's actually been found to predict whether best friendships maintain over time. Do we provide that identity affirmation? The other thing that's just really important is perspective taking. Unhealthy relationships, toxic relationship. Often there's a breakdown in perspective taking. I'm thinking about my needs. I'm not thinking about your needs.
因此，仅举一个我在书中做过的采访为例：这位女士在疫情期间生病了。她不确定是什么病。她原本应该和她的朋友去参加一个舞蹈比赛。她说：“我不能去。我生了重病。现在是疫情期间。”她的朋友说：“我真不敢相信你抛弃了我。
So just for an example of an interview that I did in my book, This woman got sick during the pandemic. She wasn't sure what it was. She was supposed to go to a dance contest with her friend. She says, I can't. I have a serious illness. It's a pandemic. Her friend says, I can't believe you abandoning me.
你是个糟糕的朋友。”那个朋友显然只想着她自己的需求。我希望我的朋友出现在这个舞蹈比赛中，但根本没有考虑她朋友的需求。因此，在健康的关系中，我们需要找到那些平衡自身需求和我们需求的人，并尝试合作，找出以双赢且适合双方的方式来处理事情的方法。你知道，现在有很多关于“幽灵”（ghosting）——即那些突然音信全无的人——的讨论。
You're a horrible friend. That friend clearly is only thinking about her needs. I want my friend to show up to this dance competition, but not thinking about her friend's needs at all. And so healthy relationships, we want to find people who balance their own needs and our needs and try to collaborate and figure out how to navigate things in a way that is a win-win and suits both of us. You know, there's a lot of talk these days about ghosting people who just sort of drop out.
你以为事情进展得很顺利，突然之间他们就不回你的电话和短信了。你怎么知道自己已经被“幽灵”了，是时候放弃了，这个人以某种方式在给你信号，但又不是直接告诉你“我再也不想见到你了”？这真的很难，老实说，友谊比任何其他关系都更倾向于充满模棱两可。这是因为，你知道，在我们的婚姻中，我们有一份正式的合同，让我们彼此连接；在我们的家庭中，这是血缘。但在友谊中，你根本不知道期望是什么，你总是得去摸索。因此，当谈到“幽灵”现象时，我喜欢保持乐观的气氛。如果我一直没有收到某人的回复，我喜欢假设他们很忙，你知道的，给予他们这种包容，不要把这当作针对个人的事。
You thought things were going well and all of a sudden they're not returning your calls and texts. How do you know when you've been ghosted and it's time to just give it up that this person is somehow giving you a signal but not a straightforward. I don't want to see you anymore. So it's really hard because honestly, friendship, more than any other relationship, tends to be a relationship of so much ambiguity. And that's because, you know, in our, in our marriage, we have this formal contract where we're connected and our family, it's blood. But friendship, it's just you don't quite know what the expectations are and you're always just trying to figure it out. And so when it comes to ghosting, I like to maintain an air of optimism. If I haven't heard back from someone, I like to assume they're busy and, you know, give them that grace and not take it as personally.
我认为这是一个很好的初始假设。我认为当你退一步审视友谊的宏观全局时，这种“幽灵”行为是否反映出对友谊整体缺乏投入或兴趣？对吧？当我们一对一互动时，他们是如何表现的？他们愿意进行一对一互动吗？他们面对面互动吗？他们看起来感兴趣、投入吗？当我们一对一互动时，他们会肯定我吗？
And I think that's a good starting assumption. I think when you take a step back and look at the larger landscape of the friendship, does this ghosting reflect a larger lack of investment or interest in the friendship, right? How are they showing up when we interact one-on-one? Are they willing to interact one-on-one? Are they in doing they interact face-to-face? And do they seem interested, engaged? Do they affirm me when we're interacting one-on-one?
所有这些都是信息。而不回复你的短信，应该成为更广泛信息领域内的一个数据点，对吧？单凭某人没有回复你的短信，并不表明他们试图“幽灵”你或结束这段关系。所以我认为这需要我们退一步，更广泛地评估这段友谊的全貌，以弄清楚到底发生了什么。我说过，人们对友谊中的冲突感到非常害怕，以至于宁愿直接结束友谊，对吧？但实际上，科学发现，当我们对关系中的问题进行公开、共情地讨论时，
All of that is information. And the sort of not responding to your text message should. be a data point within the larger realm of information, right? The fact that someone didn't respond to your text message alone does not indicate that they're trying to go send you or end the relationship. So I just think it takes us taking a step back and evaluating the landscape of the friendship more broadly to try to figure out what's going on. And I say, like, people are so afraid of conflict and friendship to the extent that they'd rather just end the friendship, right? but actually the science finds that when we have open empathic discussion of issues in our
我们往往会体验到更多的亲密感。因此，如果你只是在逃避冲突，你实际上可能正在损害你的友谊。事实上，我认为很多人逃避冲突是因为他们认为：“哦，这样更好。你知道的，我不会提起这个。我不会引起所有这些紧张局势。”但紧张局势已经存在了。问题在于你是否能够克服它并拥有那个机会。所以这是另一回事。
relationships, we tend to experience more intimacy. And so if you're just avoiding conflict, you might actually be harming your friendships, actually, because I think a lot of people avoid it because they think, oh, it's better this way. You know, I'm not going to bring this up. I'm not going to cause all this tension. But the tension is already there. The question is whether you can work through it and have that opportunity or not. And so that's another thing.
如果有人对你“幽灵”而你不确定，我会建议发起一次对话。比如：“嘿，我一直没收到你的回复。不确定是不是有什么事。如果是这样，我只想欢迎你提出你的任何担忧，因为我随时倾听。”所以再次强调，这实际上就是展现自我，冒一点险，并希望得到一个好的回答。绝对是的。我的意思是，连接就是这样一种裂痕：它感觉像是我们可以参与的最冒险的事情，但同时也是最具滋养性和最重要的事情。
if someone's ghosting on you and you're not sure, I would just invite a conversation. Like, hey, I haven't heard back from you. Not sure if that's because something might be going on. But if so, I just wanted to welcome you to bring up any concerns that you have because I'm here to listen. So again, I mean, it's really about putting yourself out there and taking a little bit of a risk and hoping that you get a good answer. Absolutely. I mean, connection is this sort of schism of being the most risky thing we feel like we can engage in, but also the most nurturing and important thing we can engage in.
它既让人感到恐惧，又同时无比美好。家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日大促现已开启，您的夏天从现在开始。是时候用 Next Grill 四燃烧器燃气烤炉开启夏日烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以使用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅招待客人，仅需 499 美元。今年阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。
It's both petrifying and gorgeous at the same time. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove Seven-piece Outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices, guaranteed at the Home Depot.
售完即止。价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。仅限美国，有例外情况适用。详情请参见 Home Depot.com 上的价格匹配页面。你不是说这里离水边只有几步之遥吗？我们只是还没找到那几步在哪。我们省了多少钱？够了。够去迷路的了。
Lost supplies last. Price in valid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost.
或者你也可以预订希尔顿酒店。欢迎来到您的海滨房间。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿 App 上预订，最高可省 20%，获得您所期望的住宿体验。当您想要省钱而不是惊吓时，您住在哪里就很重要。
Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay.
希尔顿，期待您的入住。我想回到你刚才谈到的一个话题，即男性和女性在友谊方面的差异，特别是你关于男性的看法，这让我觉得非常悲伤。我在主流媒体上看到过文章，讨论女性如何更擅长交朋友以及维持这些友谊。
Hilton, for the stay. So I want to go back to something that you were talking about a little while ago, the differences between men and women and friendships, and especially what you were saying about men, which struck me as being very sad. I've seen articles in mainstream media that talk about how women are better at making friends and maintaining those friendships.
有没有研究支持这一点？是的。嗯，确实有科学发现，男性在友谊中往往不那么容易展露脆弱。科学发现，人们越是毫无保留地展露脆弱，就越受人喜爱。人们对那些袒露脆弱的人感觉连接更深。因此，虽然我们可能因为脆弱潜在的负面后果而害怕它——比如，“哦，别人会利用这个来对付我、剥削我”，但事实上，根据科学，更有可能的结果是它将巩固连接，让我们更亲密。所以我认为很多时候，男性的友谊问题实际上是伪装起来的脆弱问题。
Is there research that backs that? up? Yeah. Well, there is science that finds that men just tend to be less vulnerable in their friendships. And vulnerability we find in the science, the more people disclose vulnerably about themselves, the more liked they are. And people feel more connected to people that disclose vulnerably. And so while we may fear vulnerability for its potential liabilities, like, oh, someone can use this against me and exploit me, in fact, the more likely outcome, according to the science, is that it's going to cement the connection and bring us closer. And so I think a lot of the times men's friendship issues are actually vulnerability issues in disguise.
《大西洋月刊》上有一篇非常有趣的文章，探讨了男性在友谊中往往需要第三个客体。他们一起看球赛。你知道的，他们一起进行一项运动。这是通过有一个第三个客体来关注，从而避免展现脆弱的一种方式。但同样，这对友谊造成了极大的损害。但我必须指出，还有一种现象叫作“同性恋恐慌症”（homohysteria），即男性对被误认为同性恋的恐惧。因此，这对男性的影响是，他们觉得自己无法做出所有
There was this really interesting Atlantic article that talked about how men often need a third object in their friendships. They're watching the game together. You know, they're playing a sport together. And that is a way to avoid vulnerability by having a third object to focus on. But again, to the great detriment of the friendship. But I also have to point out there's this phenomenon called homo hysteria, which is men's fear. of being perceived as gay. And so what that does to men is they feel like they can't do all of the behaviors necessary
建立连接所需的行为，因为这可能会被误认为是同性恋。所以我甚至听男性说过：“我甚至不能主动联系另一个伙计。我不能说：‘嘿，我很想一起出去玩’，因为他可能会觉得我对他在性方面感兴趣。”因此，由于我们将对兴趣或亲热的绝对任何迹象与某种性兴趣混为一谈的方式，这让男性陷入了一种真正的困境，他们觉得：“哦，我根本不能参与这种关系，因为那样会被视为带有性色彩”，但随之而来的却是真正的孤独。男女之间的柏拉图式友谊呢？男性更容易发起或维系这种友谊吗？男女之间的柏拉图式友谊。
for connection because that might come off as gay. And so I've even heard men say, I can't even initiate with another guy. I can't say, hey, I'd love to hang out because he might think I'm interested in him, like, sexually. And so because of this way that we conflate absolutely any sign of interest or affection with some sort of sexual interest that leaves men in a real bind where they feel like, oh, I can't engage in this relationship at all because then it's going to be perceived as sexual, but then they're left really lonely. What about platonic friendships between men and women? Are those any easier for men to initiate, navigate? Plotonic friendships between men and women.
嗯，我的意思是，显然存在性兴趣方面的困难，这取决于双方是否都是异性恋。对此有一些有趣的科学研究发现，女性实际上往往比男性觉得与女性朋友更亲近，而男性觉得与男性朋友更亲近。但实际上，男性要么觉得与女性朋友比与男性朋友更亲近，要么觉得亲近程度相当。因此，与他们拥有的女性朋友相比，男性实际上并没有报告说与男性朋友感觉那么亲近，因为男性通常通过与女性的友谊获得更多的脆弱感。所以我认为这是一个真正的……你知道的，当我们谈论男性被发好人卡（进入“朋友区”）时，我会觉得：“你知道的，根据科学，这应该是一种荣誉”，因为男性与女性的友谊是他们拥有的最好的友谊之一，
Well, I mean, there is the difficulty of obviously sexual interests, depending on if both parties are heterosexual. There's some interesting science on this that actually women tend to feel closer to their woman friends than men, their male friends. But men actually either feel closer to their woman friends than their male friends or feel equally as close. So men actually aren't reporting feeling as close to their male friends compared to the woman friends that they have because often men access more vulnerability through their friendships with women. And so I think that's a real, you know, we talk about men being put into the friend zone when I'm like, you know, according to the science, that should be an honor because men's friendships with women are some of the best friendships
因为当男性与男性交朋友和与女性交朋友时，往往看起来不同的是，他们能够获得那种脆弱感。话虽如此，当男性与男性交朋友时，他们比在女性周围时能获得更多的轻松感和放松感。让我们换个话题，聊聊过去两年。在疫情初期，有很多关于如何在保持社交距离的同时维持友谊的讨论。我们都习惯了诸如 Zoom 快乐时光和在线游戏之夜之类的事情。回想起来，你认为这场疫情会长期影响人们的友谊纽带吗？
that they have because what tends to look different when men become friends with men versus woman is that they are able to access that vulnerability. That being said, when men are friends with friends with men, they access more ease and more of a sense of relaxation than they might access around women. Let's switch gears and talk a little bit about the past two years. At the beginning of the pandemic, there was a lot of talk about how to maintain friendships during social distancing. And we all got used to things like Zoom happy hours and online game nights. Looking back, do you think the pandemic will affect people's friendship ties in a long-term way?
我们现在甚至知道吗？你知道，这里的研究实际上褒贬不一，发现疫情确实加剧了孤独感，但随后我们似乎又不那么孤独了。我认为部分原因在于，我们不得不接受这样一个事实：我们需要主动维系友谊。我们不能只是消极地参与友谊，并指望：“我只要靠我们每个月在某人举办的聚餐上见面就行了。”我想，在这场疫情中，我们更多地了解到，我们实际上必须主动出击来维系我们的友谊。这是一个非常重要的技能，我真的希望我们能
Do we even know yet? You know, the research here has actually been mixed in finding that, you know, the pandemic has promoted loneliness, but then we sort of haven't been lonely, have been less lonely. And I think part of that is we've kind of had to reconcile with the fact that we need to to initiate with friendships. We can't just passively engage in our friendships and rely on, you know, I'm just going to rely on us meeting up every month at the potluck that someone runs. We've learned, I think, a little more in this pandemic that we actually have to initiate to keep our friendship. And that is such an important skill that I really hope that we can
把它带入未来。如果我们能真正将其内化，那么从长远来看，它确实能让我们的友谊变得更好。我担心的是那些长期感到孤独的人。你知道的，我们从科学中得知，孤独不仅仅是一种感觉。它是一种看世界的方式。孤独的人实际上往往不喜欢他们与之互动的人。他们报告说不那么喜欢自己的室友。他们报告说不那么喜欢人类。他们报告说不那么喜欢与他们互动的人。他们报告说，在实际上并非如此的时候，却假设别人会拒绝他们。这是因为，你知道的，从历史上看，当我们感到孤独时，我们与部落分离了。所以我们处于危险之中。因此，当我们感到孤独时，我们的危险信号会以某种方式触发，
take into the future. And if we can really internalize that, then it can really make our friendships better in the long run. The thing that I am worried about is for those of us that have been chronically lonely. You know, we know from the science that loneliness is not just a feeling. It's a way of seeing the world. Lonely people actually tend to dislike people. They interact with. They report liking their roommate less. They report liking humanity less. They report liking people they interact with less. They report assuming people are going to reject them when they aren't actually. And that's because, you know, when we were lonely, historically, we were separated from our tribe. So we were in danger. And so our sort of danger
这使得我们很难走出孤独，因为，你知道的，如果你认为没有人想听到你的声音，而你其实也不太想听到他们的声音，你在贬低连接的价值，尽管你同时又渴望它。当我感到孤独时，我被拉向两个不同的方向。人们报告说，既想从人群中抽离，又想同时建立连接。因此，当孤独根深蒂固时，摆脱它变得非常困难。但我总是相信这是可能的，我认为我们需要保持乐观。我就是这样告诉人们的。因此，当感到孤独时，他们可以提醒自己：“哦，并不是我真的不喜欢这个朋友。”
signals are just going off when we're lonely in ways that make it hard to come out of loneliness because, you know, if you're thinking nobody wants to hear from me and I don't really want to hear from them, I'm devaluing the value of connection even while I wanted at the same time. I'm pulled in two different directions when I'm lonely. People report wanting to withdraw from people and wanting to connect at the same time. So it just makes it very hard to get out of loneliness when it's really, really entrenched. But I always believe that it's possible and I think we need to maintain our optimism. And I tell people that. So, they can remind themselves when you're lonely, oh, it's not that I actually don't like this friend.
并不是他们真的在拒绝我。可能只是因为我很孤独，而这正在塑造我此时此刻对事件的解读方式。”所以对我们许多人来说，工作为成年人交朋友提供了机会。但现在随着远程和混合办公的发展，这改变了许多人的动态。对于年轻人来说，比如刚参加工作第一或第二年的新人，以及可能开始远程担任新职位的更有经验的员工来说，这肯定尤其艰难。所以你最近写了关于如何在远程工作时结交职场朋友的方法。你推荐了什么？所以我建议在虚拟环境中建立持续的、无计划的互动。当我不再见到我的职场朋友时，我只是在我们的日历上安排了一个每月的会议，让我们能够互动。
It's not that they're actually rejecting me. It might just be because I'm lonely and that's shaping how I'm interpreting events right now. So for a lot of us, work provides an opportunity for making friends as an adult. But now with remote and hybrid work, that's changed the dynamic for a lot of people. And it's got to be especially tough for young adults, say, in their first or second job, as well as more seasoned employees who might be starting a new position remotely, let's say. So you recently wrote about ways to make work friends even while working remotely. What did you recommend? So I recommend setting up continuous unplanned interaction virtually. So when I stop seeing my work friends, I just set up a monthly meeting on our calendars for us to interact.
我们在现实生活中使用的一些策略也可以应用到职场中，比如简单地肯定对方。我们没有意识到，根据推断吸引力理论，人们往往喜欢喜欢自己的人。因此，如果我们能向人们展示我们喜欢他们，他们就会想与我们建立连接。所以只要说：“我重视你，我感激你，我想念你”，这些都是巩固和维持连接的事情。同样，我们需要即使在虚拟环境中也要主动出击去建立这些连接。
It's some of the same strategies that we use in person that can apply in the workplace to, like simply affirming each other. We don't realize that according to the theory of inferred attraction, people tend to like people who like them. And so if we can show people that we like them, they're going to want to connect with us. And so just saying, you know, I value you, I appreciate you, I miss you, these are all things that cement and maintain the connection. Similarly, we need to initiate even virtually to make those connections.
这具体是什么样子的？你知道的：“嘿，我是公司的新人。我一直想结交新朋友。不知道你是否愿意建立连接？”或者：“嘿，你知道的，我们已经有一段时间没聊了。你介意在日程表里安排点时间吗？我很想了解你的近况，”
What does that look like? You know, hey, I'm the new person at work. I've been wanting to meet new people. Was wondering if you'd be open to connecting. Or, hey, you know, we haven't chatted in a while. Do you mind if we put something on the schedule? I'd love to hear about you. and checking about how you've been.
并询问你最近过得怎么样。职场连接的科学非常有趣，因为研究实际上发现，我们与人们互动越多，我们感觉就越亲密，但在职场中情况却恰恰相反。我认为这实际上是因为我们在工作中往往不分享脆弱感。因此，我们总是只与彼此的单一维度进行互动。所以我还鼓励多一点脆弱感。比如：你最近怎么样？开开玩笑，做一些你在工作环境中有时觉得心里没底的事情。
The science of connecting at work is really interesting because studies actually find that the more we interact with people, the closer we tend to feel, but at work it's the opposite. And I think that that's actually because we don't often share vulnerably at work. And so there's this way that we only interact with a single dimension of each other all the time. So I just also encourage a little bit more vulnerability. Like, how are you doing, cracking jokes, things that you sometimes feel iffy about doing in a work environment,
就是这样，我知道人们很害怕，事情可能会被用来对付我，这种恐惧是真实的，但你可以透露很多关于你自己的安全的事情，比如你的胜利或成就，或者你的爱好，或者你的周末计划，只是感觉可以自由地多分享一点关于你自己的事情来建立这种连接。我想说的最后一点是，有一个我称之为“雇员神话”的概念，即当我们去工作时，我们只是变成了雇员，我们不再有基本的国民人类需求，比如归属感的需求，而这根本是不真实的。拥有连接网络与你的敬业度、你的生产力、你的创造力、团队能取得多大成功以及你留在那里的可能性息息相关。
There's just, I know people are scared, things can be used against me, and that fear is real, but there's just so many things that you can disclose about yourself that are safe, like your wins or your accomplishments, or your hobbies, or your weekend plans, just feeling free to share a little bit more about yourself to create that connection. And the last thing that I wanted to say is there's this idea that I call the employee myth, which is the idea that when we go to work, we simply become employees and we no longer have fundamental human needs, like the need to belong, and it's simply untrue. Having connection network is related to your engagement, your productivity, your creativity, how much teams can succeed, how likely you are to stay in the
事实上，没有归属感是人们在过去一年中辞职的第三大原因。因此，你建立连接的能力将对你在工作中是否感到快乐、满意和充实产生强大的影响。所以这真的很值得。你还写过关于跨种族友谊的文章，并引用了这样一项研究：人们与自己种族群体以外的人接触越多，他们的偏见就越少。你能谈谈这一点，并就如何建立跨种族友谊提供一些建议吗？因此，跨群体人们之间的接触实际上被认为是打击偏见的最有力方法之一。但需要注意的是，这必须是高质量的互动，
job. In fact, not belonging is the third reason that people have reported quitting their job within the last year. And so your ability to create connections is going to have a powerful effect on whether you feel happy and satisfied and fulfilled in your work. So it really is worth it. You've also written about cross-racial friendship and cited research that found that the more contact people have with others outside of their racial group, the less prejudice they were. Can you talk about that and maybe offer some advice about building friendships across racial lines? So contact with people across groups is actually found to be one of the most powerful ways that we found to combat prejudice. But with the caveat that this has to be quality interaction,
有一项研究实际发现，当人们倾向于参加工作活动时，他们往往会觉得与工作中的人更亲近。但这在人们进行跨种族互动时并不成立。这是因为当人们进行跨种族互动时，他们没有进行那么多高质量的对话。他们参与对话更多是为了在工作上取得进展，而不是为了真正相互连接。因此，我们需要进行更多高质量的互动，其中包含共同的脆弱性，
And there's a study that actually found that when people tend to attend work events, they tend to feel closer to people at work. But this isn't true when people are interacting with people across races. And that's because when people interacted across races, they weren't having as much quality conversation. They were engaged in the conversation more so to get ahead work-wise rather than to actually connect with each other. And so we need to have those more quality interactions where there's shared vulnerability
并且我们正在讨论实质性的事情。但当我真正建议进行跨种族连接时，是要保持一种叫做“习惯性开放思维”的品质，这基本上意味着：放下你所有的刻板印象和先入之见，对吧？我认为有时我们试图过度认同不同种族的人，让他们觉得：“哦，我们了解他们”，但最后他们实际上感觉被严重套上了刻板印象。所以不要那样做。
and we're talking about things of substance. But what I really suggest when you're connecting across race is to maintain something called habitual open-mindedness, which basically means put all your stereotypes and preconceptions aside, right? I think sometimes we try to over-identify with people across races to make them feel like, oh, we know them, but then they actually end up feeling really stereotyped. And so don't do that.
你知道的，不要试图去接近某人并说：“是的，我也庆祝这个我根据你的身份猜测你可能会庆祝的节日。”你知道的，把这些放在一边，让他们向你展现自己，作为一个人向你敞开心扉。让他们向你展示他们真正是谁。我还想谈另一个时事话题。过去几年里，人们一直在讨论政治极化如何使家庭和友谊纽带变得紧张。人们可能会感到有压力去维持与一个在政治观点上不和的家庭成员的关系。你认为有可能与我们强烈、强烈不赞同的朋友保持密切关系吗？
You know, don't try to approach someone and say, yeah, I also celebrate this holiday that I assume that you might celebrate based on your identity. You know, just leave that aside and let them show themselves to you and reveal themselves to you as a person. Let them show you who they really are. One more current topic that I wanted to talk about. There's been a discussion in the past few years about how political polarization is straining family and friendship ties. People might feel pressure to maintain a relationship with a family member they disagree with politically. Do you think it's possible to maintain close relationships with friends we disagree with very, very vehemently.
我确实认为这是可能的。当人们在考虑是否要维持这些关系时，我建议他们退一步，权衡这段关系的整体利弊，对吧？这意味着，当你决定是否与一个新朋友（他可能有着与你的政治信仰所表达的非常不同的价值观）交朋友，还是与一个你永远的朋友（他仅仅因为你们可以一起回忆过去并拥有这些共同经历而为你提供许多不同的好处）交朋友时，你的权衡考量是不同的，对吧？所以你只需要退一步，想想这个人可能
I do think it's possible. What I suggest to people when they're figuring out whether to maintain these relationships is to step back and consider the larger pros and cons of the relationship, right? And so what that means is there's going to be a different calculus when you're deciding whether to be friends with a new friend who maybe has very different values than you that are expressed in their political beliefs versus a friend you've had forever, who's providing you with a lot of different benefits just because you can reminisce and you have these shared experiences together, right? And so you just have to take a step back and think about this person may have
我的确认为这是可能的。当人们在权衡是否要维持这些关系时，我给他们的建议是退一步，考虑一下这段关系的整体利弊，对吧？这意味着，当你决定是否与一个新朋友交朋友时——这个朋友可能有着与你截然不同的价值观，这些价值观体现在他们的政治信仰上——与一个你认识很久的老朋友相比，你们会采用不同的权衡方式。这位老朋友能为你提供许多不同的好处，仅仅因为你们可以一起回忆过去，拥有这些共同的经历，对吧？所以你只需要退一步，想想这个人可能
different values than me in this way. But what are the things that I also get out of this friendship? And how do I weigh those two things together? Because all of our friendships should be more good than that. That being said, there are people who might be like, you know what? Having different values, having different politics is too much of a con for me. That's something that I weigh heavily as a con. And I don't think there's an amount of pros that could counteract that. And I say, you know, we all need to develop our own system. We all need to go through our own self-reflective process to understand what our needs are and what our values are and what we are and what we are willing to compromise on and what we're not.
在价值观上与我不同。但从这段友谊中我也获得了什么？我该如何权衡这两者？因为我们所有的友谊都应该利大于弊。话虽如此，有些人可能会觉得，你知道吗？拥有不同的价值观、不同的政治立场对我来说是个太大的缺点。我把这视为一个很重的缺点，而且我不认为有多少优点能抵消这一点。我说，我们需要建立自己的系统。我们需要经历一个自我反省的过程，去理解我们的需求是什么、我们的价值观是什么、我们愿意在哪些方面妥协，又有哪些不能妥协。
That being said, you know, I know from theories of racial identity that people of color who tend to go through experiences of discrimination then tend to go through a hibernation period where they only want to interact with people from their group. And so what that research sort of suggests is there can be times when we feel like we need to hibernate for our own safety, but that also doesn't necessarily last forever. And so we need to also expect that sometimes when we have these differences and things that feel so valuable to us and that feel like they're part of our identities like politics tend to be, that sometimes there'll be periods where we might need some space, but we might be able to reengage in their relationship over time. So I think, too, when we're making friends across difference, we should expect that there's going to be a little bit more ebb and flow. So as you're working on the book and you're reading all the research into friendship, are you finding areas where either the research is surprising, that the results are surprising, or that there are areas where you think, boy, we really need to know more about this. Yeah, I mean, the surprising thing I've learned since studying friendship is that a relationship is a relationship, right?
尽管如此，据我所知，从种族认同理论来看，经历过歧视的有色人种往往会经历一个“休眠期”，在此期间他们只想与自己群体的人互动。因此，这项研究所暗示的是，有时我们会觉得为了自身安全需要“休眠”，但这并不一定永远持续下去。所以我们也需要预料到，有时当我们存在这些差异，并且这些差异对我们如此宝贵、感觉像是我们身份的一部分（比如政治倾向往往就是如此）时，有时会有我们需要一些空间的时候，但随着时间的推移，我们也许能够重新建立这段关系。因此我认为，当我们跨越差异去交友时，我们也应该预料到会有更多起伏。那么，当你撰写这本书并阅读所有关于友谊的研究时，你有没有发现哪些研究结果令人惊讶，或者有哪些领域让你觉得，天哪，我们真的需要对此了解更多。是的，我的意思是，自从研究友谊以来我学到的令人惊讶的事情是，一段关系就是一段关系，对吧？
And what that means is what makes our romantic relationship succeed makes our friendship succeed. affirmation of another person, working through conflict empathically, vulnerability, right? But the problem is I think we tend to compartmentalize a lot of these skills to our romantic relationships. People are so used to working through issues in their romantic relationships because if they weren't, their relationship would end. And yet they don't transfer those skills to their friendships, right? And so that's what I want to share. Think about transferable skills. What are skills you've developed from your marriage that you can bring into your friendship to make it better in that same way. And the other thing that I would say is that,
这意味着，让我们浪漫关系成功的因素同样能让我们的友谊成功。对另一个人的肯定、以同理心解决冲突、展现脆弱，对吧？但问题是，我认为我们往往把这些技能很多都隔离开来，只用于我们的浪漫关系。人们习惯于在浪漫关系中解决问题，因为如果不这样做，他们的关系就会结束。然而他们却不把这些技能转移到友谊中，对吧？这就是我想分享的。想想可迁移技能。你从婚姻中培养了哪些技能，可以把它们带入友谊中，以同样的方式让友谊变得更好。我要说的另一件事是，
you know how I talked about are the liking gap and our bias to assume people like us less than we do. That's true across the board with all different types of intimacy. There's this phenomenon called the Beautiful Mess Effect, which finds that when we are vulnerable, we think people are judging us more than they actually are. There's studies on affection in friendship that finds that when we share affection, we assume that people will think it's more awkward and be less grateful than they actually are. And so when it comes to connecting, I should say, we really need to tune in to our self-defeating thoughts and recognize that we may have some biases involved and to maintain optimism to assume that people like us, that they want to connect with us, that they're going to enjoy
你知道我之前说过的好感鸿沟以及我们假设别人不像我们喜欢他们那么喜欢我们的偏误吗？在所有不同类型的亲密关系中都是如此。有一种现象叫做“美丽混乱效应”，它发现当我们展露脆弱时，我们认为别人在评判我们的程度超过了实际情况。关于友谊中表达喜爱之情的研究所表明的是，当我们分享喜爱之情时，我们以为人们会觉得这更尴尬、感激之情会比实际更少。因此，当谈到建立连接时，我应该说，我们真的需要调整自己的自我挫败想法，认识到我们可能存在一些偏误，并保持乐观，假设人们喜欢我们，他们想与我们建立连接，他们会享受
the interaction, that they're going to value the things that we do and value the things that we've invested into the friendship. Dr. Franco, I think you have given us some really good advice about how to be friends, get friends, maintain friends. Thank you so much. And I hope our listeners really get something out of this, particularly during the pandemic, where it's been such a strain. So keep those connections, gang. Absolutely. Thank you so much for having me. And if you want to stay connected with me, you can follow me on Twitter or Instagram at Dr. Marissa G. Franco.com. I also have a assessment for your friendship, strengths, and weaknesses on my website, www.w.m.mrissaG.franco.com.
这种互动，他们会珍视我们所做的事情，也会珍视我们对友谊的投入。弗兰科博士，我认为您给了我们非常好的建议，告诉我们如何交友、获得朋友和维护朋友。非常感谢您。我希望我们的听众真的能从中有所收获，尤其是在大流行期间，这种关系承受了如此大的压力。所以，各位，请保持这些联系。绝对的。非常感谢邀请我。如果您想与我保持联系，可以在Twitter或Instagram上关注我：Dr. Marissa G. Franco.com。我的网站上还有一个评估您友谊优势与劣势的测试：www.marissaG.franco.com。
and I speak on friendship and belonging within and outside the workplace. Thank you so much for your time. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.org or on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you're listening to us on Apple and you like what you hear, please leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan.
我还在工作场所内外就友谊和归属感发表演讲。非常感谢您抽出时间。您可以在我们的网站 www.apa.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 以及您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学对话》以前的节目。如果您在 Apple 上收听并且喜欢您听到的内容，请留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学对话》由李·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。我们的音响剪辑师是克里斯·康迪汉（Chris Condihan）。
Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学协会。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。